after more than a decade of handheld  titles and digital releases Mario Tennis  finally returns to consoles as mario  tennis ultra smash unfortunately while  the game might recapture the light rkd  gameplay that made the originals a blast  to play with friends it also cuts many  of the modes and much of the bonus  content that gave those games variety  plus ultra smash never teaches you how  to use its new or old mechanics which  will inevitably lead to some annoying  losses early on without substantial  content to drive longevity you may end  up switching back to Mario Kart sooner  than later but if you're playing online  or better yet with friends at home  you'll likely overcome the game's  frustrations and squeeze the solid few  hours of fun out of its fast-paced  powerup driven action